so these are the eight areas where the
government has issued additional
guidance around mixing and travel
that's because they have high case rates
largely as a result of the more
infectious
indian variant bolton tops the chart
with a rate of 451 cases
per 100 000 people with blackburn with
darwin
second with 281 all are well above the
england average of 23 cases per 100 000.
local authorities say they're not in
lockdown but would a tear system of kobe
destructions
hold back the virus well let's take a
look at what happened last autumn as
cases began to build from a summer low
this was the picture in mid-october much
of the country was in tier one with a
rule of six
or tier 2 which banned indoor mixing
but liverpool and some surrounding areas
had just gone into tier 3 with a ban on
socializing altogether
in the city cases roughly halved from
659 for every 100 000 people
to 317 in three weeks but
elsewhere cases continue to rise until
the national lockdown in november
so tough restrictions may work however
scientists believe success is more
likely if they cover large areas
and of course they have to have the
support of local authorities
the indian variant which lies behind the
current rise in cases has already spread
well beyond the hot spots 97 local
authorities have now had at least five
cases
which may cede new outbreaks and
scientists believe it will shortly
replace the
kent variant as the dominant strain
nationwide
but there are two key differences this
time compared to last autumn
one is surge testing now done by local
public health teams rather than test and
trace
in the sefton area of liverpool is
helped to bring daily cases down
from 36 to just four in less than a
fortnight
and the other is vaccination with every
passing day around
200 000 people get their first dose
another 400 000 get their second
so two doses give good protection
against the indian variant
the slower the spread of the variant the
more time for the rollout
but tiered restrictions are unpopular
and
toxic politically so whatever their
scientific merits
they are unlikely to happen